dans l' affaire grégory villemin les
deux dernières journées de
reconstitution commencé aujourd'hui à
vaucelles dans les vosges homme discret
et minutieux le président simon tente de
déterminer l'endroit exact où le petit
grégory a été jeté dans la vologne il y
a un peu plus de trois ans
reconstitution difficile qui débouche
sur un échec tout au moins momentanée
sur place le reportage de roland sicard
pour le juge simon l'expérience des
mannequins devait être décisive elle
pose en fait plus de questions qu'elle
n'apporte de réponses tout l'enjeu était
d'établir si grégory a pu être assassiné
à l'extérieur du village de dos elle
rester dans un premier temps le
mannequin a coulé très rapidement mais
dans une seconde expérience il a franchi
les obstacles qui le séparait du centre
du village là où le corps de grégory a
finalement été retrouvé dans cette
hypothèse la culpabilité de christine
villemin serait toujours envisageable je
pense qu'il ya dans ce dossier des
charges extrêmement sérieuse
ce n'est pas moi de les apprécier je ne
suis pas un adepte de la chasse aux
sorcières je constate et j'en tirerai
plus tard avec m lagrange avec le
professeur jacques les hôtes et les
conclusions qu'ils s'impliquent
si grégory a été assassiné à l'extérieur
du village loin des habitations le crime
aurait pu être commis vers 17h un moment
où aucun témoin ne peut confirmer lampre
du temps de christine villemin seulement
pour la défense l'expérience des
mannequins est loin d'être concluante si
le pauvre petit grégory avait été jeté
au fameux endroit prix légers moi je
pense qu'ils se seraient rapidement
enfoncé dans l'eau comme le premier
mannequin mais même s'il avait flotté il
y aurait eu un phénomène de sharjah
jaune contestable il ne serait pas
arrivé au lieu où on l'a découvert qu'il
se trouve à 400 mètres plus loin sans
porter la moindre ecchymoses donc ça
c'est extrêmement important
ce soir le juge simon en main l'ensemble
des éléments du dossier un dossier
auquel il manque sans doute toujours
pourtant la preuve qui pourrait
permettre d'éclaircir trois ans après
les faits le mystère de la mort du petit
grégory